but but most people think and they here
and now so if you tell someone in the
healthcare sector we know which is a
growing sector that things used to be a
lot worse there and things are getting
better there's more employment this is a
growth industry but they don't see it
that way because they're earning 15,000
quid a year they're having a tough time
so you're gonna have to refer back to a
time and in their lives or their parents
lives which they're just not in touch
with emotionally well it's that's not
exactly right the idea that that
populism comes from people who are
reflecting on their own life
circumstances and are angry about it
it's not quite right because polls show
that most people in the United States
and in Britain are actually pretty happy
with their lives
however if you ask them about everyone
else's life they think oh my god the
country is going down the tubes my kids
schools are my kids school it's pretty
good the nation's schools oh my god
they're you know even if we're not
miserable yeah I think we're miserable
all the people's bones oh well a lot of
it is that the portrait of society that
people get from from the media there are
certain features that are almost built
into conventional journalism that are
bound to give a distorted picture of the
world first of all the fact that bad
things can happen quickly good things
aren't built in a day as max Rosa the
economist at Oxford put simply papers
could have had the headline 137 thousand
people escaped from extreme poverty
yesterday every day for the last 30
years but they never had that headline
with the result that a billion and a
quarter people escaped in extreme
extreme poverty in our lifetimes and no
one knows about it and if you ask people
in polls has extreme poverty globally
gone up gone down or stayed the same
the vast majority people say that it's
that it's it's gotten worse and that the
fact is it's gotten better by a lot so
this is a major fact about the world
some development economists say this is
the most important fact in human history
that billions of people have been lifted
out of poverty in just three decades and
no one knows about it
you